it is time for the greatest debate I am
Chris Kohler this is wired and we are
gonna sit down with the gang from Smosh
games to talk about the best games of
all time the best games of all time two
of us are going to pick out what they
feel are the best video games of all
time in a series of genres they're gonna
have twenty seconds each to make their
case everybody gets a ten second
rebuttal and then our crew of judges
defined as whoever is not currently
debating make sense are going to decide
who wins ready first person shooters
sohinki
versus lasercorn no I think the best
first-person shooter of all time would
have to be half-life half-life the rich
universe of half-life with black mesa
you got Gordon Freeman it was just a
revelare a revolutionary first-person
shooter was named actually game of the
millennium by PC gamer when it came out
it was an incredible game that spawned
actually all of your favorite games as
well you got tf2 or sorry not skeptical
Team Fortress county etc etc oh that's a
halo too better than counter-strike I
just had so much fun and because I based
my best first-person game on the most
fun I had in the multiplayer and Halo 2
was the most fun multiplayer dual
wielding vehicle jacking fighting on
Zanzibar on the giant wheel we had so
much fun with that game and the feeling
you get as you soared someone and black
on and charge and rip the head off with
the sword is the best feeling I've seen
great but halo is just a little too
floaty the the gameplay in half-life is
just better and you mention
counter-strike which is another mod that
spawn from half-life considered the most
balanced shooter of all time so I didn't
mention counter
and in halo vehicles vehicles make the
game you can fly around above the map
you can see what all the other people
are doing and then like dive bomb them
or run them over the okay judges halo 2
was a lot more fun to play I am you
brought that to light I'm gonna go halo
half-life introduced the crowbar which
was very important and interesting so
I'm gonna go with half-life half-life PC
gamer that's it half-life is better than
Halo 2 Anna's first-person shooter of
all time you heard it here first
2d platformers joven Shire versus Chris
Kohler ready yep Super Mario Bros 3 is
absolutely the best platformer game ever
made of all time it is incredible and I
will tell you why it has curb oshu mario
gets to take a shoe the green shoe from
the Goomba get inside of it and start
jumping around like crazy sure it only
occurs in one level but that one level
was the best platforming game level of a
time uh you want to talk about a green
shoe you can step in how about super
mario world introducing the one real
green part you need Yoshi not only did
it bring an extra dinosaur that you can
ride and help you against your enemies
and give you an actually hit of damage
but also this game's worlds were huge
and do I need to mention the funky
stages if you can get all the different
star roads Yoshi breaks Super Mario
World there's so many crazy things you
can do in mario world but it doesn't
make it like a really fun freerunning
crazy running jumping Mario game anymore
Mario 3 is a pure experience the reason
it's broke is because people have been
playing it for years and years and years
finding every little way you could
possibly beat the game and having that
much depth in a game is amazing plus
ghosts house the music I'm gonna take
you to a vote and I gotta go with
nursery I too am a huge yoshifan and
Joey did bring up Yoshi gonna have to go
with Chris he brought up a lot more
points you were arguing against his
points but he brought up a lot more
things about his
well you've convinced me to it good job
Mario World is better action-adventure
lasercorn versus Mari now Arkham City
one of the best action-adventure games
of all time
and basically it had the best story
Joker was insane maniacal in that and
the twist at the end I'm not gonna get
into spoilers but it was awesome and the
combat was amazing counters and attacks
and all the gizmos and gadgets it was so
good
aside from that it was really good
thousands create Black Flag that is the
best game it is so gorgeous it's
beautiful not only do you have the main
storyline you can have an entire ship a
battle on a ship
you mentioned gadgets um hello create
them lit come on uh but you know what I
mean good jab in your head
hidden blades are not as cool as the
gentleman you could spray on the ground
and then explode later that is way
better explosive detonating gel and I
don't even remember who the villain from
Blackhawk war zoo's supportability
companion app that keeps you in the game
I will absolutely argue with for that
think it's amazing you get to continue
with your ships ten points accessories
are what made these games great and a
man has more accessories gonna give the
Batman yeah as much as I hate to agree
with joven if you're arguing gadgets I
feel that Batman probably has the better
gadgets and you brought up an app which
who cares about I'm gonna say yeah
existence of a companion app automatic
disqualification
role-playing games Chris Kohler versus
joven Shire
listen clearly the best RPG of all time
is Final Fantasy 6 right it's got
amazing graphics for the Super Nintendo
it's got the most incredible soundtrack
ever a touching story of human beings
just trying to find their place in a
crazy world twelve different main
characters amazing gameplay materia and
the weather to the south
I'm gonna go with Final Fantasy three
actually musics great but that's what I
look at the depth of every character and
the way that they fight every character
has a different ability that they can
use and its unique plus this game the
world becomes destroyed and is nothing
and it's only the halfway point in the
game oh there's still more time before
about your completed Final Fantasy 6 is
way better than Final Fantasy 3 Final
Fantasy 6 is just extraordinary it's the
pinnacle of the genre I mean again I
don't mention the soundtrack can you
mentioned 12 characters I'm pretty sure
Final Fantasy 3 has a lot more than 12
maybe that may be the same actually mine
had a game like Terra saving shadow
these are all great mergers it is a
tough one but the way Chris described
Final Fantasy 6 just his love of the
world and how it was the pinnacle of he
seemed to have more passion you ran out
of time talking about yours I have to
agree with lasercorn Chris also
mentioned soundtrack thank you both
nerds I don't know either game I'm just
going to just not vote you brought up
the music on music your Final Fantasy
game was almost as good as my my music -
right right also I am not the same thing
realtime strategy lasercorn versus
sohinki
take it away all right Starcraft
unarguably the best game of all time I
mean you've got memes in it like dirt
rush is like common terminology now
because of that game it applies to other
games no game has had this bigger impact
on eSports and stuff like that if you
must construct additional pylons another
thing people know that haven't even
played the game ask any South Korean
partner there's a corn imma let you
finish but Warcraft 3 is the best RTS of
all time in addition to the rich lore in
the game it added the hero mechanic
which maybe seemed a little outlandish
to normal RTS people but it added an
element to the game that gave it another
layer of depth that just wasn't there in
StarCraft and it also spawned games like
like dota and all the different tower
defenses and stuff which Starcraft had
but not to the same degree and not as
popular wasn't dota started by an
abstract in Starcraft and also uh your
game Warcraft 3 took away sea battles
from Warcraft 2 which was one of the
most fun parts of Warcraft 2 what the
hell are they doing over there Aeon of
strife but the popular version of dota
is DOTA allstars which was in Warcraft 3
also it had south bar tower defense
which tsunami commodities lasercorn was
angry and passionate I'm gonna have to
go with Starcraft yeah I'm totally
swayed by the ask any South Korean
argument I mean when an entire country
is lined up behind one game I mean what
is that
so winky fit all the debate that he
needed to in less time than given and I
award that and I still win sports mario
vs. joven Shire the best sports game of
all time is NBA Jam 93 came out on the
Sega Genesis that is my childhood you've
got flaming basketballs from downtown
you say that to anyone in our generation
they still know exactly what that is
yep Scottie Pippen and Horace Grant
Chicago Bulls you can't you have to win
with
sometimes the greatest people in history
are the unsung heroes and I say Looney
Tunes be Vaughan now this was a game
that took all the Looney Tunes care
design we're serious this is a real
argument this game was so amazing
because you had all the different Looney
Tunes characters all of which had
different abilities so you can collect
items and gems around the field allowing
you to do said abilities in the game was
very difficult this game NBA chip was
the best arcade game of its time and you
know what I know I still have some time
but then argument is done
boom-shaka-laka
I'm gonna say what's up doc Oh that'd be
my three-pointer from across the other
side of the court with a piece of
dynamite attached to it so anyone who
tries to block it boom
you're just pile of dust now it was
class a very heated debate I think it
all comes down to the catchphrase mari
dropped boom Shakalaka boom Shakalaka
what's up doc that's not even a thing
I gotta go with me plan I'm going to be
puzzles lasercorn versus Chris Kohler
[Music]
it's got to be portal 2 it's gotta be
portal 2 you everyone in there mom knows
it's portal 2 it had the best puzzles
the best lines you have the gute all the
stuff you loved from portal 1 +
repulsion gel + Cave Johnson + Wheatley
plus the awesome I don't want to spoil
anything but the awesome scenes in the
end where you know what happens with the
stuff it's temptress actress
may be the best game of all time
incredibly simple it's just seven shapes
and two of those shapes are just mirrors
of the other shapes it's this remarkably
elegant simple game that has endured for
decades upon decades since its release
people still trying to master it Tetris
is 100% the best puzzle yeah when it
came out it was great but you know what
else medical leeches were great when
they came out - but we've moved out we
have better medical practices we have
baedal better games and portal 2 is
clearly a better game
I'm sorry portal 2 is a neat game two's
a neat game Tetris the best puzzle game
of all time I'm really trying not to be
biased because I love portal 2 but Chris
made a really good point it is an unjust
you don't solve Tetris you continue to
try to solve Tetris and it is a puzzle
game I gotta give it to Chris and web
portal 2 but I gotta get I I do give you
the fact that Tetris might be one of the
greatest games of all time but in your
speech you're like Plus this Plus that
Plus this Plus that texture something
has plus this piece plus that piece plus
this song Plus this piece portal do I
love portal 2 I have a personal vendetta
against when people say that Tetris is
the greatest game of all time I played
that game when I was 3 you put the
shapes in the holes put the shapes in
the holes you know when you're doing a
little baby and you have like the the
moon shape and you have a star and
you're like that doesn't go in the moon
that goes in the star but let's be
honest he had you at leeches that was a
good analogy yeah that's fighting Mari
vs. sohinki mari you have the floor nope
just super smash come on it is
everything that we have have played in
our childhood and now we have it for the
Wii you ain't man smash we've got so
many characters you've got all these new
smashes it's amazing it's beautiful so
many levels you've got I gotta go
Ultimate Marvel vs. Capcom 3 you have
some of your favorite characters from
the Marvel and the Capcom universe is
coming together to duke it out some of
the coolest combos strung together in
such like balletic is that a word
fashioned just strung together and like
it just get the most hype responses from
people watching this game it's
incredible to watch in the sports world
mentioned hype what about Megaman what
about pac-man what about Little Mac what
about duck hot song I mean you might
have those characters but there's also
cool characters in umvc3 as well as
people that are just so incredibly good
at the game that you can even help but
marvel marvel at how good they are much
as I want to say Super Smash Brothers
because it reinvented what a good
fighting game can be with a percentage
beater I know people that that dropped
out of college because they were playing
Marvel vs. Capcom so that one you know
you must have noticed the tone in my
pocket which means you were playing to
the judges biases so I have to go with
Smash Brothers
I am also incredibly biased and I love
smash brothers and have spent about zero
time with Marvel the so I got a fighting
game of all time that about wraps it up
for those age old debates I would say
you guys I mean geez people argue all
the time about what the best video game
of all time is and so it just it's just
so great to get to just settle it
completely in forever
so thank you all very much everybody for
being here definitely if you want to see
some more subscribe to the wired Channel
but see more of me subscribe to Smosh
games to see more of these guys and if
you think that you disagree with us
about what the best video Kate's a
father I can't imagine why you would
know what you know well no no not at all
but if just in case you do consider
leaving a comment down there and letting
us know what you think the best games of
all time are thanks everybody for
watching oh yeah